Train by day Joe Rogan podcast by night,
all day
two,
one Yamaha.
And we're live.
Ladies and gentlemen,
this is a fight companion podcast.
What that means is if you've tuned in hoping to hear enlightening conversation
or facts about the universe or ancient civilizations and run,
he comes to the wrong place pitches.
This is a bunch of people that shouldn't be awake but are awake at 5:00 AM I'm
with a j Blah Aka Eddie Bravo.
Kill a bee.
Ben Saunders is up in this bid.
Sure what's happening.
And then of course Brendan motherfucking shop a big Brown,
he k big brown sexy
and uh,
we're here watching the UFC live from North Korea.
Yeah,
rest four minutes and 40 seconds.
Who would you give the round two that's different.
It's not the same is the same.
You described a totally different situation around and he got knocked down.
Round means more at the end of the guy would personally count.
I said,
Doug,
how you're doing towards the end of the talk over each other please.
That's not the way the rocks,
the biggest star was coming back.
Is He?
What's going is all talk,
but I don't know.
You know,
there's all sorts of talk,
but I,
you know,
I had heard a lot of talkers,
Bronto,
then we can't talk over each other,
so people will listen and there's no way this is going to work.
Someone's,
he's just a head of tech people get,
they're just better.
They're just like Marcello's.
When I was watching lines up with the weight,
has anyone else
tried,
try this guys,
we can't talk over each.
Sorry.
How much would you like to see him versus Damien Maia?
He's going to out strike everybody.
I'd like to see him fight.
Can't take him down.
I haven't seen it.
The wonderful wonder.
Oh yeah,
I got a lot.
Of course.
Edgy Bra,
also known as Eddie Bravo.
It's your Bra.
That's what they taught when we were in Brazil.
That's there.
They call me.
The issue is Joe Moran were those,
the first giant tournament that there was an la Joe morale.
He was the main promoter and in my division it was 45 guys were all blue belts
and my division.
He's,
and you got to sit there and listen to him.
Call out everyone's name and I'm sitting there,
I'm waiting for him to call my name is he?
Look,
he looks at the clipboard.
Then he looks up to the,
here's your Bra.
I'm standing right in front of him.
I'm like,
man,
when are they going to call my dad?
Like fuck.
And then someone say,
dude,
I think he's saying your name.
No Way.
Yeah.
Where's Rick Story?
Ben?
It's a long story.
[inaudible] it was the weed.
That ball landed in the bed or mine
and he probably just went to Pete's.
Fantastic.
He gets so worked up.
I was hoping you jump over here and choke the shit.
He loves conspiracy theories about nine 11 inside.
Y'All
don't,
I don't know man.
Don't answer that.
I just saw you're already smart.
Get get any another beer down real quick.
He's going to fuck this up
real quick.
Chem trails?
Yes or no vaccine.
A killer or an aid.
How many,
how many towers went down on nine 11.
Oh my God.
I know.
He knows my brother's crazy.
Like you are so and
oh shit.
Donald Serone very happy.
The fact that he knows the three towers went down means that,
uh,
you kind of,
she knows.
No.
Most people don't know that.
Most people don't know when that a press conference with Nist,
the National Institute of Standards and technologies,
they're the ones that came out and explained what happened.
Tower something.
When they asked him why didn't,
did you guys check for closeups?
It's really simple.
It's like kindergarten shit.
When they asked the head of kindergarten,
why didn't you check for explosives?
Why didn't you test for explosives on tower seven?
They said there was no reason to.
That was no taste,
no witnesses.
Meanwhile,
there's about an hour of witnesses,
firemen,
policemen saying bombs went off.
There's video of what's going on.
And the guy said,
we didn't check for bombs because there was no witness.
What about that honey who flew those planes?
Nothing.
Anybody can say.
I can say to you,
there's nothing I can say.
I provided complete video evidence for you.
I broke it down for you.
You're still,
it's still not enough how much you say nothing.
I can say
I haven't said anything.
Let me play Devil's because some guy asked me the other day if I wanted to have
someone who is a lot a flat earth proponent is apparently the best argue or for
a flat here that I want to hear that argument.
What can they possibly say?
No fucking way either trolling or retarded is weird.
Of course it's Trump,
but the one thing that's fucking weird is you would think with all the
satellites we have going in and out of our solar system and how come there's no
pictures of the earth and like the shirt,
I don't know.
It's a fact.
I'm Brian.
Yeah,
Cord Meyer was one of the top CIA guys back then.
JFK.
This was Kay was banging cored wires and wife.
So when you listen to this,
he Howard hunt concessional,
he said Lyndon B Johnson straight at the whole thing.
He in.
He's telling you how I see AI engine famous on his step by saying,
you look at,
we was cord Meyer cord.
Meyer wanted him denser Lyndon B Johnson.
He had court [inaudible].
Look how much the time that he bravo spent smoking weed peering out curtain
senior first play that.
Are you shocked or something?
People are dying all the time.
Did you know during the day,
like this is some wide open.
She did.
You know how many astronauts died in 1968 to eight and then two more on 69 what
happened?
What are they doing?
Oh,
I'm flying into space accidents.
His father,
Prescott Bush started the CIA,
his father,
Prescott Bush finance the Nazis through union bank.
That's not a conspiracy theory that hold on.
You know in Sweden for many years,
they sterilize kids that didn't have symmetric,
perfectly symmetrical faces.
That a fact.
It's actually nice.
That's some shit.
That's why they're so good looking.
I don't know.
I'll look into it.
You think you think that's crazy?
Pretty crazy.
When you say look into it,
did you look into it?
I got to meet her now.
Everything that's coming through the major news that works all have an agenda
behind it,
whether it's district,
because if I was running shit,
I would,
if I was wanting to shit and they said,
hey,
what do you think we should do?
I'm like,
wait a minute.
Are you guys controlling the media?
First of all,
if they say no,
we're not really controlling the media.
They do whatever they want.
I would say control the Goddamn meeting.
What the fuck are you guys?
How would I get my information at the library guys?
I go to the library,
apple bottom.
I'm so bullish on the fucking Internet.
Who goes out?
Library,
the library.
You guys get your information from the Internet.
I go to the library.
Our library.
How you see the Internet as if it's all the same source he did.
He was in this amazing documentary and just a fucking life changing documentary
called the principal.
Have you seen that?
No,
I have not.
Fuck,
and Michio Kaku was in it.
A bunch of physicists,
like professors from Mit.
That's so funny.
I just saw the documentary sugarcoated.
Oh my God.
Have you seen it?
It's terrifying.
Holy Shit.
Real quick documentary.
This is,
this is one that I've watched over and over.
It's really,
really good.
If you say it's the best of all.
No,
it's not.
It's not.
But it's really,
really good because,
especially for conspiracy theorist type,
it's called how big oil conquered the world.
There's a documentary called the fence will blow your fucking mind.
They never finished that.
They abandoned it.
It's deserted.
Mexican dudes are going,
what are these Americans doing?
They're interviewing Mexicans.
I'm just like,
this is easy.
This documentary's called about the birth of oil and how it came in and infected
all our lives and how John Rockefeller monopolized fucking everything to find
that dude.
It's,
it's an incredible,
and it's free on youtube.
Yeah.
That's a big red flag there.
Hey,
there's a documentary you can watch on Youtube.
Oh,
here.
Jay.
The untold story.
His son
or Netflix.
Oh No,
it's at the library,
Bro.
The Sugar Association.
They didn't want it to be labeled as for what it really was,
uh,
an addictive toxin.
They want her to keep it at.
Ain't that bad in moderation.
It ain't that bad.
It makes things taste sweet.
It's about love.
They tell you,
they tell you we don't know shit.
We're looking at a bunch of lights and the God,
Scott,
you're going to tell me that that light and that light that's 250 a hundred
trillion light years away.
How the fuck did you figure that out?
Learned.
Well,
don't they have an explanation for that shit?
No,
exactly.
That's what every what you just said right now.
But what you just said,
now's what?
Everyone's natural reaction.
Cause anytime someone says anything about space,
you automatically think someone figured it out.
You don't know the guy's name.
You don't know the name of the experiment.
You didn't look into it yourself.
You just think when someone tells you how far is the earth from the sun?
Oh say oh 93 million miles away.
Like you just write.
You will.
Everybody relies on someone figured that out and someone double checked it.
Dude,
it's math,
it's science,
it's math.
But no one really knows.
So they,
they paid according to this documentary,
they paid off Harvey.
You know,
cause everyone's like,
I'm flying,
I'm science.
This,
That it's beautiful when people do that because then all you do is buy off all
the scientists and you got everybody.
I love some sugar though,
man.
Yeah,
we can all be bullshit.
Those documentaries gate so juiced up.
They're so,
they're so juicy.
They seem so good.
They seem so real.
You get fired up and then once you get fired up,
it's tough to get unfired up.
I want to be in the Goddamn it a little naughty if their Goddamn,
listen,
of course you do.
Just
the military,
the military credit for all the great music that came out of the 60s you fucking
military scenario.
You are fucking shell
to start my own false flags.
Jones is going to call you a shell Monday morning we got a disturbing turn of
events at Eddie Bravo I've had on this podcast.
I did not know he was in the Illuminati Shit.
Fuck yeah,
he is on the Joe Rogan experience.
Yes.
Yeah.
Trails proven to be false.
Fuck yeah.
I want a fucking,
oh my God,
you're in.
If Oh,
please let me,
let me get this straight.
My own fault.
I would,
if I would get that fucking oil from Alaska,
I would go in there and make it,
make it an elect.
Trump make it look like the eye.
Isis is uh,
uh,
Eskimos are trained in Isis.
I would,
you know,
you're a national treasure and I love blue.
Blue whale was a national trend.
None of these things are true.
It has to be frustrating.
Eddie to believe something.
He goes,
you constantly have to back years ago and it is very exhausting.
When I post a meme,
I can see like people,
I could see my a followers rise,
but what I post anything like,
uh,
anti vaccine and he kinda dude hundreds.
It's like 72000.8 and then he goes,
it's 7.6 reach to do what people don't like.
Conspiracy.
[inaudible]
I lost.
You know what?
I cleaned them out.
It's a filter.
I needed to clean those fuckers out.
Someone did come up to me and say,
hey,
you heard that conspiracy theory where there's no forests?
Have you heard about this?
There's a conspiracy theory where there's no chorus.
Look into it.
No,
no forest.
I bet you love these things.
I'm like,
I don't know what that is.
Really.
I didn't even look,
I watched 30 seconds cause someone in class told me a Ziggy came up.
You have your debt conspiracy theory about no,
I go,
what did,
I went home and I put no forest and I was 13 seconds.
I just stopped it.
Have you seen the one with this to do to the dinosaurs aren't real.
Have you seen that one?
That I don't have that I don't know.
I don't know.
That's like some other shit where I'm like,
I don't believe any science.
I don't believe in that.
The only science I believe that you rub two sticks together and there's fire
that's other than that,
you've got to prove that.
I'm going to ignore that shit.
All you gotta just tobacco science.
What about that,
that you think that Shit's gone?
I don't know a Frankie signs because you don't know fighting bro.
How'd he say his name and what's his background?
Turn this up.
Do you know?
We have a timeshare in town.
I would,
you'd be saying translate.
I just want to thank Brian going for Zach.
Here's my big inspiration is my pleasure for me to watch him so much so I wish
he was here and to kiss him just one time.
His Lips.
I know he's married and he's skinny,
but he's a beautiful eyes.
Would,
how would Joey translate what she saying?
Listen,
Ron,
I'm coming for you.
[inaudible] mom,
put your fucking beans and rice and following a child's and half mass.
Is it possible for Joey d to do to impression of Conor McGregor?
Is that even possible?
Possible.
We would have to watch them,
but if you do an impression of Joey doing an impression of what kind of allowed
you to take part cock sucker.
Who's done what I've done done.
Who's done?
Who's done fuck,
I'm doing this shit for island dog.
What the fuck?
Fuck.
Eddie Bravo.
I love how he calls your,
your full name.
Brendan Sharp.
Openly gay.
Play by play commentator.
Commentate this fight and
Brazilian.
This guy's
delving
oil.
I have questions.
I'll be answering you.
It's just sweat.
It's not,
it's not an oil sweat for a debt for their body on body.
Like
they're just working out really hard in your body.
Your body heats up and um,
hit hit all the here.
Yeah.
Why?
Why are there so strong?
Because they're fighting.
They're fighting other men.
They have to be strong.
Otherwise you get your ass kicked and you know you want to protect your joints
stuff.
Well,
you know the closer,
I'm pretty tight.
They've got quality Reebok gear on here,
cops and stuff.
Everything's fine.
You don't have to worry about that.
Okay.
You are you smelling good?
You are in general.
The shower day and I just got back from Paris,
smell like a bear and I smell like as far as just my leg,
the forest.
Brian,
do me a favor.
Tell them the dream you had that you told me.
I tell them the dream thing.
Tell me if this is normal.
I think it's appropriate.
Okay.
This is my business partner.
Listen to this dream.
I had a boyfriend.
Okay,
that's not Martin Luther King.
And what were you doing right
now?
Listen to this shit.
Any fuck me get a dream.
He's having sex with a man.
Well,
I'm glad you told me this after I told Steve Rinella that I don't want to share
a tent with you because he asked me.
He goes,
is it okay if you're sure Taylor,
Brian,
fuck yeah,
I do.
I still like a werewolf.
You look like a snoot I'm assuming.
No,
I have an irregular NASA.
Craziest,
craziest,
loudest snorer
mouthpiece of a new malware.
When we went hunting
third or fourth version,
cause I was linked up fitting,
right man.
I kept falling last one.
Yeah,
I kept falling out.
But the new one is,
it's uncomfortable but it fits great and it keeps my tongue in place.
Makes no sound to sleep like a baby.
I make no sound.
Finish your gay story though.
I'm sorry.
And I was like,
and I was like,
I'm straight man and I have a boyfriend and this guy keeps fucking me
dream.
I was like straight as shit and this guy's fucking me and I got to keep this a
secret.
I'm not sure how to make sense of it is that
he was dead serious when he told me this and I literally just looking at what it
is,
Bro.
She next hour,
it's
Yay,
right it town right down.
The possibilities are endless with this drain can go wherever dream like that
ever in my life,
dude.
I was like,
and I was like,
and the guy,
but I back,
he had a back on him and I was like,
damn man.
And I remember
I didn't tell you this part in cocktails,
we're having cocktails and I was looking at her.
I go,
I fucked this guy again.
I was like,
yeah,
Fuck Shit.
It was crazy
straight man.
I'm fucking straight
disturbing how many jokes you have like arguing your sexual,
I know it's like a big part of your act as arguing your sexuality.
I was like,
he's 50% gain.
I don't have the issue with it.
I've hypothetical conversations with important people in my life and then when I
seen it goes nothing.
You have a hypothetical adversarial conversations about important.
When you're ready for the conversation,
you're ready and you're like,
fuck,
he crushes you.
No,
no.
It means this becomes all friendly.
How's it going?
That's it.
I do the exact same thing.
And what I also do the fuck you talking about,
he's crazy.
He's what he's telling you what I use.
If somebody did something that I was like,
Whoa,
that's Kinda mean,
or whatever,
then I'll extrapolate and I'll be like,
what did,
he was that way all the time.
And then what if he shoved me and then I want to be called me a bitch and then
I'll just keep calling before know what?
I'm having the same exact thing.
I'm having a verbal argument in my car.
I have done that.
I have done,
yeah,
you're right.
No,
I get you now understand he explained it better.
You're thinking,
okay,
this is motherfuckers going to come at me with this and he's going to come at me
with that.
Well,
I got this right to him and I got that right.
Correct.
And you're like practicing through the whole thing.
Yeah,
I do that.
I think everybody does that.
I do something even I think I do something even more ridiculous.
I daily have a fantasy that I live in a part of the world where gangs are
running everything and you are terrorizing my village or Los Angeles run.
And what I do then is I secretly,
I push a cart of food cart.
I'm humble,
but I have a small gun with a silencer and I kill all the bad guys quietly.
And they're like,
well fuck,
it's killing us man.
What the fuck is going on?
And I'm like,
would you like another,
a lot of the professional.
Yeah.
That's literally how I think about how I protect myself.
Totally Sane.
All of you.
I feel Eddie Bravo.
That weird.
I'm sorry.
I thought something similar.
I thought,
no,
this isn't what I'm talking.
What if,
what if you could figure out how long it takes to kill someone with the choke
and then how long it takes to put them in a vegetative state permanently.
You mastered that.
Interesting.
So like anybody,
like you're like a vigilante and anybody who deserves to be a vegetable,
you're not going to kill him.
Child molesters.
And you hope you have a timer,
you got 45 seconds,
you let them go in their vegetable.
If you didn't kill him,
that's genius to kill him.
But they're like,
hold on,
I hold a timer and I hope the time one by one you just turn
vegetables.
That's amazing.
[inaudible] maker.
But then there's a guy that you didn't hold that choke long enough and it wasn't
lined up right.
He's look,
oh,
you're like fuck.
You got to put them in another arm trying to,
you're like,
oh shit.
Get change it to an arm triangle and you fucking,
oh,
I need 15 more seconds.
Fuck.
The cops are showing them God damn.
And then you let them go on then.
So basically you guys want to be like fake superhero.
He's a vigilante.
Going to be super,
there's a sick play.
There's a sick play called the Toyer that's called veggies.
Look,
there's festivals everywhere and they're like,
detectives are just like out.
They're all bad guys.
Yeah,
exactly.
All the festivals would I go to jail for holding the tires?
It's like Jujitsu.
Dexter.
I'll tell you what,
I'm more excited for them to even pack y'all Mayweather is,
I've been talking Shit to count about his taekwondo days for years now.
His wife has proof,
I guess,
of what look at the past.
So yeah,
there are pictures of me.
Ah,
she has pictures of them probably flying through the air.
Killing a cow.
That's nothing to be proud of.
If you have a shiny Sol,
like that's terrible.
You got to pick your knee up.
You have a,
nope.
See,
it's not bad,
but you have an inherent flaw in your technique that probably was never,
never explained to you for 49 no,
it ain't bad.
It's pretty good.
It's just not right.
I wouldn't want to get hit by that.
I wouldn't want to get hit by hitting them.
Riding a shaft.
That's where you would get hit.
What did you,
did you really get a black belt?
I was a master.
Come on,
come on.
I don't know what he's really good about his rank master.
What does that mean?
Let me back.
I went back to the,
how long did you train?
Probably seven years straight.
Seven years straight.
And where were you living?
All through college.
You must have been training when I met you then and then three years after it by
just,
just stop and I wasn't,
I wasn't sparring that I'd probably stop just then.
So when did you get her black belt?
Uh,
in 1987
I used to being serious there.
Are you being serious?
Show me.
Show me a real front lake side for re Hobble Shit.
Oh Bullshit.
Well just this from here and just throw it.
Sure.
Let me see the spinning one though.
The woods.
The spinner one kick.
Yeah,
that's my favorite that he does.
It's my favorite.
Too Old.
Oh dear you.
You just,
all you have to do different now.
All you're doing wrong.
It's,
you're coming up.
You're foot is going up from the ground like in almost like a half moon.
Yeah.
You want to get your knee up higher.
That's one of the cool things about those genes.
Tell him never saw him compete.
I was competing with her.
I have to find my library of video.
I'll show you all that trophies will actually keep.
I gave,
my trouble is to Jeremy.
I had the melted down to the local orphanage.
We were basically,
we were probably in the same weight class is,
which is so confusing.
I traveled all over the world.
Country at least same Aau didn't you?
I thought all style really.
Cause I was fun.
Merican taekwondo championships.
I did that.
I did get WTF dude,
I'm standing right here.
I don't throw the kick into your knees.
Up Hot.
Lift your knee up way high past your waist and then throw the kick.
Yes,
me up first and then don't look over your stomach.
Look over your shoulder.
Yeah,
but knee first here.
Hold on.
This fucking hysterical.
This
while I'm drunk.
I can't watch
my park pass to Joe was going to go off.
Dude.
Genes on genes.
On genes up here,
up here,
up here.
So flexible pipe companion from here.
Turn your shoulder to the right.
Turn your shoulder to the right to the right.
Now extent,
extent straight.
Don't look over your stomach.
Look over your shoulder like this.
Like that.
That's how you look.
I know that's not yet flexible.
Flexible.
You're fine.
Left right from here.
Watch.
Oh sons.
Damn.
Even in the eds,
fucking chuck Norris blushing.
Lift your knee up and then kick.
I still think John Claude van Damme beats the fuck out of both of you.
Then kick watch that one too.
Okay.
Ready?
I'm not mad at Joe's format all.
No,
I never saw you.
Never heard of you know,
but heard of you ever.
You Bro.
Not doing any
title.
Do you Eddie,
you buy believe him.
Why would he let me be very clear.
I actually wouldn't lie about winning.
Just don't think you.
I think you did taekwondo.
Thank you.
Anything you like a blue belt or something at the time when you were in the
national office that will be using that you won the nationals as a black girl.
I fought the,
I fought hard to believe.
I'm throwing it up here.
I'm like this.
I'm never like this.
Look at Joe's ass.
When he throws the kick,
it's just looking at it.
Don't look at,
don't look at the foot.
He has a set of hunting and look at the foot do's on right into the glutes.
Look deeply into them.
Dude,
I'd love to see our actual taekwondo match,
shrink Callen and relevant.
I would just stare at their asses.
Do it my barbells,
huck and monster.
They're awesome,
right?
Yeah.
Well,
you see my cakes?
Yeah.